c'est important le sens non mais c'est
important ça va porter le sens il est je
vous avais moi j'ai 21 ans bon d'accord
quand j'entends des propos comme ça ça
me
m'accable parce que moi ça fait 32 ans
que je travaille avec les jeunes j'ai 62
balais ça fait 30 ans que je fais ça
dire ce genre de choses qu'on voit dans
quel état est déjà l'école les profs ou
à choquer dans ce que je n'aimais pas ce
que vous dites le ca va pas rayer des
inégalités c'est parce qu'on cherche à
faire non plus le but
c'est un argument qui a été avancé par
eric zemmour franchement on s'en fout
problème le fait d'avoir de données du
vivre ensemble de donner du sens aux
gamins moi je vais t'expliquer une chose
john holmes ça fait trois ans que je
fais de la société non mais attends des
choses comme ça ça ne savait pas où ça
bac avec les jeunes si j'y suis toute
l'année avec les chabal je vous le dis
qu'on avait des jeunes avec des gens de
ton achat prises des epide par exemple
l'établissement public d'insertion dans
l'emploi tous ces jeunes sont des
détenus 20 visites et tu verras ce que
c'est c'est autre chose que les
quartiers parisiens
ont
commencé a dit ne prenez pas de
chiffres
trois manches sable jeux le procès en
parisianisme je trouve que
bruno né sur le fond sur le fond le faut
sur la vie des fidèles ça fait trente
ans que je reçois des centaines et des
milliers de jeunes par jean part de 8 à
22 123 ans de tournage ils sont tous
habillés avec des t-shirts tous parés à
l'école pour moi je pourrais je reprends
l'exemple des épis des établissements
publics d'insertion de l'emploi sont des
choses formidables je sais pas si tu
connais 18 25 ans des gosses qui sont
revenus dans le cursus scolaire qui
arrivent tous avec des tenues ça donne
du sens à ces gamins et ses gamins
sortent tous impeccables de ces
dispositifs deviennent pendant quasiment
un an voilà ça c'est les choses
concrètes et le fait de donner du sens à
conduire à la tenue et au comportement
c'est essentiel mais je pense que ça
d'abord d'abord c'est pas une idée de
zemmour c'est bayrou qu'il avait déjà
proposé ça
mais c'est quelque chose avait cédé
sinon qu'est ce qu'on fait
vous parlez du sanctuaire à celle
sanctuaire un péril l'éducation à
remettre des cas la parole c'est moi le
maître d'école c'est moi c'est pas des
objectifs de gommer les inégalités la
gestion des mandats comme moi j'ai eu la
chance de faire l'équipe de france de
rugby pendant huit ans j'ai été en
nouvelle zélande gt n a fait une chute
j'étais d'un des pays surtout s'habiller
où et quand les écoliers mais sauvé
parce que nous nous entraînions sur leur
terrain dans leur collège ou dans leur
lycée et j'avais pour coutume de faire
le que c'était un nouvel de l'acca de
leur collège mutuelle tu pleures comme
tu vois ça et oui et tu vois si cinq
gamins qui ont le même uniforme d'accord
alors tu sais pas effectivement nous il
y as certainement des inégalités chez
eux je suis encore une fois mais il ya
un respect et quand tu arrives là que tu
les vois tu te dis ils sont tellement
fiers de leur école mais ça commence par
ça l'éducation sur les pas fier de son
école de son maître de son professeur
d'éducation physique alors on fait ce
qu'on fait en france je leur crache
dessus olé olé olé tabasser moi c'est
pas un problème d'éducation je les ai
vécus et crois moi quand tu pars de la
et des joueurs qui font ça mais qu'ils
étaient menés sur la vesa si on avait ça
donc encore une fois c'est pour
l'uniforme pour l'éducation le respect
et une autre anecdote champions arrive
quand ils jouent et illustre joueur de
rugby capitaine de l'immense joueurs de
runes quand ils jouissent à toulouse
elle disait il avait dit au président
que témoin président à l'époque le rugby
était amateur il y avait des chirurgiens
des agriculteurs des employés municipaux
il y avait de tout belge une équipe et
il avait dit le jour du match je veux
que tout le moins de soi billets de la
même façon voilà n'est pas d'inégalités
on est là pour la même chose pour
représenter le club dacquois je ne veux
pas qu'on dise je suis là il est mieux
habillée que je sélectionne on est tous
habillés pareil on se ressemble et on
défendre la même cause bernard m'a
convaincu j'ai institué la blouse pour
les chroniqueurs oui en quelques mots
ensuite leur
maladie
du coup
apporté chat moi je leur ai dit mais
c'est pas parce que vous habiller tour
de la même manière que les inégalités
mais bien sûr
j'ai l'impression que j'ai l'impression
que vous en fait le reproche de pas
vouloir donner du sens au chaud mais
louis je le promets à dire il faut
donner du sens à l'école et je suis le
premier à dire mais une perte de sens à
l'école particulièrement dans la
jeunesse je suis aussi là mon engagement
c'est de dire qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
perte de sens mais alors le bon sens
mais si jamais votre solution pour
redonner du sens à l'école ça c'est les
jeunes des pommes mais c'est déjà
quelque chose mais attendez c'est ce que
tu as causé d'autres et j'ai déjà me
louis est partie d'arguments d'effacer
les musiques et les inégalités là je
suis d'accord avec louis c'est pas parce
qu'on va mettre un vêtement à tout le
monde qu'on va les effacer mais quand
même ça permet quand des familles sont
en difficulté et des enfants se sentent
mal à l'aise parce que certains ont des
marques au d'autres c'est très concret
de dire au moins on n'a pas ce combat
l'a amené à l'école c'est très difficile
quand on est une maman ou un papa ne pas
pouvoir mettre les vêtements que
l'enfant voudrais pas ce que les autres
le met les finir on a eu pas les
inégalités mais ça aide quand même et
ensuite il ya le côté de la fierté
d'appartenir à un établissement et ça
souvent les élèves leur bandits qui sont
très contents d'avoir des uniformes dans
certaines écoles parce qu'elle est que
son parce que ça peut être une blouse et
c'est la fierté appartenir un groupe un
établissement ça va pas tout résoudre
mais néanmoins je trouve que c'est une
base effectivement et c'est un dress
code parce que l'école ça se respecte
quand on va à l'école eh ben on doit pas
être habillé n'importe comment et comme
il ya des enfants qui viennent habiller
n'importe comment au moins ça permet
d'avoir des enfants qui sont habillés en
respect ce qu'ils auront à faire de
toute façon dans leur vie après